I'm gonna mainly Q&A so you'll probably
all get your questions I'm trying to be
the hot tip to anybody who doesn't
because I appreciate being part of first
in line thanks for being an agent 2021
how's it going so far
anything stand out awesome great so
let's just go into Q&A so hey how are
you rob commentary on comm I've invested
about 9,000 and Facebook this is war but
thank you than anything else
9,000 Facebook YouTube pre-roll over the
last year since last year turn that into
about $90,000 insufficient income my
Direct Mail is also killing it too which
is wonderful I've got about a thirty
thousand dollar online budget what would
you suggest in terms of the long term
brand building play should I max out
what I'm doing in terms of direct mail
is not as good a space book here's why
not going to do fit no no the question
is do I do
do i triple down on facebook and youtube
with this market content and retarget or
do I invest in doing more of a
widespread content play to do more
Instagram and LinkedIn and that you
haven't even remotely begun to feel the
effects of Facebook nine to ninety
thousand is good 90,000 to nine hundred
thousand to better said has stumbled out
on Facebook and go all in there or 10x
you got it
I apologize because I want to add value
to I'm trying to give answers that will
add value to everybody and what I'll be
right there and when you get to ninety
thousand and nine hundred and then the
next day you go to a hundred thousand
but it's still ninety nine hundred
thousand you're like oh I tapped out you
didn't tap out a lot of you think you've
tapped out on Facebook
you just haven't changed the creative
yet you can't imagine in a kak LTV world
in a world where last night you were
saying we're getting leads for 250 when
you were talking what was going through
my mind was or it could be 97 cents if
they had a machine so I pretty much in
the last month I've decided I'm gonna
write a new book and I'm gonna call it
volume and it's it's gonna be about all
this which is what what when I hear what
you did off of not knowing how to do it
that speaks to me that the whole thing's
wide the [ __ ] open
that's ridiculous returns and you have
no idea what the [ __ ] you were doing
that's right so you can imagine why I'm
excited that's why I'm yelling so loud
and it's by the way it's my macro thesis
on real estate the reason we will state
so addictive
is when it's going good an ant can do
well and I don't mean your ant I mean an
actual insect so that's what's happening
with Facebook but it's more content some
of you have a thing working and you
don't realize that you should be
investing back the dollars not into more
media but into 17 different pieces of
content that you've never made before
content is where you need to be tweaking
not just segmentation and great well I
think are you did you see the Gary Vee
content model deck that I put out the 86
page deck okay so Google when you get a
chance
Google Gary Vee content model deck get
it read it really read it because it's
very very thorough and very important
and again it's like this classic thing
of like you tell people something and
you tell them and they're like yeah yeah
but they don't do it like really read it
because the answer is within your videos
right there's another 787 pieces of
content all of which will do better than
the actual videos right which is another
thing that like drives me crazy when
people are getting results when I'm like
do what I'm doing you know watch what
I'm doing not what I'm saying like even
that but even that you saying oh like
you do if you're not doing that we have
now an arbitrage opportunity right right
script the audio now you've got a
podcast right the reason video is so
powerful is it's the starting point for
everything you can do you can film one
video and you have basically video
long-form you have chopped up short form
video that over index you have a podcast
and and when you really get advanced you
have somebody transcribing it and you've
got articles and Q&A is the best because
you don't even have to do anything you
just respond so why I love when people
like I've been in business for 21 years
but what do I do
I'm like you're the best position you
know what the [ __ ] you're actually
talking about sometimes you're holding
back the truth because you make more
money in the shadows a lot of these
industries made a lot more money when
the consumer was undereducated a lot of
oh geez in here hated the internet at
first because now customers had info and
they were driving into your margin Auto
real estate right you got to lean into
waves not let them kill you
hey Gary so first of all it's a little
hard to see you on the screen that scan
where you know that hurts
I know [ __ ] that dude and so I'm in
South Florida obviously and I've
developed a little audience I mean in
real retail that's what I do it's
shopping center games that's all I do I
see where this can go
nationally were actually start investing
buy because I'm building relationships
all across the country but I also have a
job to do the least local shopping
center space at Miami I'm struggling
with how do i scale where i go from
being the local guy to how can i
leverage these relationships and help
each other because people want to mess
in Miami but I know a guy in Boise and I
want to buy something Boise
well you in the short term you can
create a referral program there's
somebody in Boise that looks like you
find her and take a big bro the amount
of things the you know the amount of
things that I saw wrong with Wine
Library the year after I stopped
operating at day-to-day that were all my
doing that were wrong was wild fresh
eyes are smart eyes if the person is
smart you know but that's what I do
create another set of content to create
the homies and home yet state you want
to jam with and create a referral
business that's what everybody did to
you guys in the industry anyway that's
what all these platforms are built on
arbitrage they used Google now they're
using Facebook I'm trying to get you to
use Facebook before they do it's the
only thing you got nothing else the
middle is finished the internet wins
hey what is up Gary vana Carrera from
Texas summer realtor this is my second
year here can I get really excited to
kind of implement and just let you know
that I did start a podcast because of
agent 20 21s here so says their
apartment crew now I got my assistant I
got my camera guy I did a bunch of stuff
that we talked about last year yes my
question for you and what happened it's
great business for me with real estate
the are a way that you talked about
macro lights is there I'm not I'm not
charging anyone for this podcast I'm
highlighting people in my city do we
make things entrepreneurs business
owners and it's really good because I'm
getting business from their networks of
course when they're promoting my
snippets they're promoting the vodka
brand always beats sales in the end yeah
it's crazy
so my question to you is I'm at this
point right now where my business my
business for real estate is great my
podcast is been something that has kind
of evolved into kind of a child of mine
I've seen Road and it's crazy because I
go out or I go anywhere people recognize
me because of the podcast it's called
whiskey Wednesday podcast sessions and
they'll tell me you're doing that does
the podcast
it's amazing but I'm ready to take it to
the next level I got my crew here that
helps me with my real singing content
and you know day to day but I want to
take this podcast to the next level so
who do I need sup look for or higher in
order for me to really take this next
what's the next level morale for me more
listeners more and more interviewers
more reach more everything my goal is to
do one podcast every single Wednesday
yesterday we dropped episode number 30
which means that since age of 21 last
year understood
so having a much too busy right now to
focus on getting people you know
scheduled are using the right questions
sounds like you've gone out I'm making
the joke of being noticed when you're
out you know um well there's only one of
two moves you either pay somebody and
add to your team and costs or you do it
so if well the making more episodes if
you're telling me that's a game of
logistics and you needed somebody to
book another twenty two people that's
who you hire but if you're talking about
I need more awareness maybe you hire
somebody to run media against awareness
of your podcast so there's the making it
and then there's the merchandising of it
everybody likes to say taking to the
next level
that's a vague ass thing that's why
these sessions are so great I get to
listen so I'm like are you saying that
it's hard to make fifty two because you
didn't have enough time to book somebody
or you know like right and the reason I
go first to how busy you are it's like
I'm just fascinated by the curve of
ambition versus execution like I you
know I really really like to really
introduce you I just want to really know
you
yeah right because if you have time to
watch anything I put out that's already
a minute I got back to make 52 episodes
I know I appreciate it and by the way
everybody listen I watched three hours
of football once a week in the fall like
everybody's got to do them but I want to
know everything you're young how big is
your ambition well guess what it doesn't
sound like to me because it's easy as
[ __ ] to get in fifty two [ __ ] podcasts
like like when I talk about how hard my
dad and I work those were real hours
they're like like I was trained and real
like like I thought we were coming home
this is how I was trained by him in the
back when we came home when we left at
seven and that was considered like this
new thing that my mom at the time at my
age this was a new thing that my dad was
coming home early because he'd been like
because he used to close which meant 9
or 10 like bro do you actually work
every minute from 9:00 a.m. to 10:00
p.m. I believe you then the question is
is it smart dude honestly straight up
because I love you
it's not hard to produce a [ __ ]
podcast 52 weeks you [ __ ] chose
something else yeah I'm like that it's
not that so that's cool that's cool like
that to me excites me because it's just
not hard it's actually stupid easy if
you're working every hour you got it
lovey-dovey I love you back doesn't open
Delaware and I'm interested in how you
cultivate a relationship with someone
like a Steve Ross so how do you go from
you know a normal person to a
billionaire relationship like that uh
for me I just let things come to me I've
never sought out a relationship in my
entire career I always thought that
having the leverage with the end
consumer brings me all the opportunity
results right I think too many people
think people want things from people I
don't want anything from Steve right so
people are like oh if I could just
become homies with Gary Vee he'll put me
on what's a lot better is me being
interested in you because then you have
the leverage got it I've never sought
out a relationship in my entire career
because I'm not looking for anything
from anybody the leverage is the
consumer not gonna let some other human
have leverage got it so I built a great
company I disproportionate index stood
for the New York Jets
the main executive that benefit Matt
Higgins profile in the NFL grew because
of our work he wasn't kidding
up there that gave him got why did Steve
want Matt because the Jets were the best
at a thing that Steve was smart enough
to understand was important so then Matt
goes there what happens next
Matt's like I need Gary in my world now
I have the leverage to sell a piece and
got it leverage hi
I remember this morning in 17 years it
might mean something it's a long it's
it's minimum ly five years away like
there's just no indication of of anybody
using it and be to be like at a
conference you can see it like you know
and like maybe in commercial it could
happen faster because businesses have
less customers so that might be a leg up
to go into an office and show somebody a
location
normal people not yet but let me tell
you the more important part of that
question everybody's looking for
lightning rods everybody always asks me
a question like that or what's next
because they want to be on that next
trend it's a game about being best not
being first everyone's addicted to being
first this is a game about being best
you know long YouTube pre-rolls
and Facebook ads had been around by the
time he ran his first nine thousand to
get ninety thousand forever got it so
like everybody here trying to catch that
next thing how about you do a decent job
in the current thing first people trying
to get on that BR train and have like
six followers on Instagram
probably firing fast you know I've
gotten way better at it but I'm still
not a natural fire I'm so optimistic I'm
always thinking like that's what makes
me great at what I do but it makes me
vulnerable and firing right I just
always think I'm gonna come up with some
new cockamamie an idea that's gonna make
it work I think it's the reason I'm
starting all these [ __ ] companies
somewhere else to go real good brother
good to see you yeah that's big trouble
for you guys I see one of them winning
and eliminating all of you yeah I think
one you know what it's the same thing
with search engines right like when
people were doing like yellow pages and
versions of that they're like they're
like what do you see happening with all
these search engines dog pile and yeah
whoo and Ask Jeeves and I was like you
know I wasn't asked questions like this
but back in the day and actually this is
not true I'm not gonna have purple eyes
it I was watching that with the theory
of like they can't all win right and
that's what end up happening and that
then became the patterns that I watched
you know like it's what happened social
networks
I knew that hi-5 and Bebo and my like
you remember social media for a few
minutes their tag world if you're an OG
like there was a lot of [ __ ] out there
besides just MySpace and Facebook and
then remember there was gonna be a
million niche social networks you know a
dog ster that was there was a million
things I knew then because of search
engines and browsers that there would be
one or two one or two of these companies
are gonna win forever do you want to
disrespect everybody and jump out go
ahead
she was saying yes she does wonder this
was not good
they know exactly what the where they're
gonna buy next Amazon has all the data
so in my opinion and I've been in it
would say 34 years I've been in
technology 15 years all I can say is
that the data is gonna win and so has it
and they have our money 3.5 billion
dollars a year which 70% where everybody
goes for short term sales so you pay
high commissions for those referrals but
then they get all the data and it's it's
over it's over it's a hundred percent
over now the only thing left is your
personal brand but you can't build it
when you're under Coldwell or Remax or
wiser so how does that play out
that's called channel conflict craft and
Pepsi and Coke or dead - because they
have a problem called Walmart and Costco
if they want to go direct Walmart and
Costco have something to say about that
there's always channel conflict during
disruption so what do I think I think
one or two of them are gonna win 100 the
Internet is gonna squeeze everything do
you know how many limo drivers never
thought the internet was a problem all
of them the right bookstore people went
first because that's what Jeff went
after first got it I wanna i want to
follow kim sting so i want to follow it
so since a lot of industries are
eventually gonna be obsolete what to you
is the safest or maybe not to say this
because I'm not looking for comfort but
your you have been a medium you teach
people you I don't know if you teach
everybody do their medium for them for
big companies is that what the industry
you recommend the most no I think what
you need to be conscious of is why
everybody's vulnerable and also
recognizing it may never happen in your
entire career like you know like it just
may no it's a timing game but to not act
as if when it's already happened is a
mistake it's already happened in your
industry these things already exist got
it in my world a lot of brands are
taking all their services in-house
that's why I have a product now called
volume model internal we're selling to
clients the following pitch hey case Wes
this is not true but I'm just saw a case
with thank you Swiss hire vaynermedia in
the first year our fees are four million
in the next signed a three-year deal
instead of a one-year deal four million
a year 1/2 million a year to 1 million
in a year 3 why because over those three
years I'm gonna give you my employees
and now they work a case Wes you have to
react to the reality of the marketplace
we don't know when but when you see it
you can't put your [ __ ] head in the
sand you see it Zillow's calling them
direct what else do you want to know you
think they're just testing it for kicks
and giggles they're gonna stop that
program you have no leverage
hey Gary I took your advice I sold my
house I love you so much you can't
imagine that really takes a lot of
strength but it's really smart if you
play it right next if you do the next
thing right you'll be happy forever okay
I would go I would go with I would go
with red
put it on red yeah an ad you mean or
stock
I guess ads cuz you said I'm a realtor
how's business why why okay and where
are you getting your business from how
many years in are you and uh and what
market is it so you know look my advice
you know everybody's gonna have a unique
situation like this here's what I would
say there's nothing if this is real
estate what you want you think at this
fear young dude do you have a
self-awareness enough feeling that this
is what you want to do or you did it
because the money looked good in the
short term no cool so that's a good
starting point because it will factor
into my advice but you know what's
interesting much what's going on with
him and whiskey and much what I was just
telling my sister outside I can't tell
you guys enough how much I want if
you're willing to build your personal
brand because you own it in perpetuity
right so if you build local celebrity
you could switch to selling ice cream
right so the answer is yes
I think you should but the problem is
you may be bad at spending it he's a
success story at nineteen ninety
thousand I don't know what he did you
may spend but what's great about
Facebook it's not like buying television
or buying a piece of property you can
rev it up so spend fifty dollars a day
eighty you don't this you know people
get cash in their pocket and they burn
my dad left me a thousand dollars when I
started my baseball card business when I
was 13 years old you know what I did I
went to Costco and because they didn't
have the cards I wanted
the money was burning a hole in my
pocket I spent it all on secondary [ __ ]
I didn't believe in but it was burning a
hole in my pocket and I had to work
harder to pay him bet I've hidden back
real fast in the scheme of things
but I would have paid him back [ __ ]
day one if Costco wasn't sold out of
what I knew I was going there to buy but
I didn't have the discipline at 13 to
not buy something because I never had
that kind of money before and I needed
to spend it that's what I'm saying to
you if you have the discipline to spend
it strategically you'll be very okay hey
how are you good please clothes funny 20
brought that up let me get a second
question I'll answer the question
where'd you come from
understand so we moved to Raleigh and
six years later we are at a point where
we are trying to do that
at least so at least that's my next goal
for this year however we spent quite
some money and time on advertising it
was Facebook especially videos Facebook
more Facebook I mean it look I know your
guys industry you have to understand you
didn't squeeze it dad I don't know if
you've heard this cuz I know you don't
consume a lot of my content I always get
upset about how much I was able to help
grow the business because in hindsight
it could have been more if I did more
Google and less star-ledger we would
have grew more I was right but I didn't
realize how right I was I was still too
young and everything else worked too
which is why is owned in on Direct Mail
right like other things work too but
something's work better and some things
go away correct that's what I mean it's
gonna go away guys Facebook's gonna go
away
Facebook's gone away from what it's not
as good as it was two years ago right
now I'm telling you that in the macro
but it's still so [ __ ] good it's good
right but in the macro I think real
owners have a long time like like when I
say you're wipe it wipes you out it's
gonna play there's two factors one how
ambitious you understand Keller and
Remax
and and Berkshire and Safa B's are gonna
have to respond to this soon people are
unhappy a brokerage is bringing no value
yeah not an Internet world where was
completely is y-you know I said it last
night so I think Vayner brokerage would
be the biggest because our value prop
would be lower commissions and I'll
build your personal brand which is the
only asset that matters you know so so
for me they're gonna have to respond
these are not small companies so
somebody you know and by the way this is
how it's gonna go down one of the big a
view a couple but you guys know better
but like one of the big four six nine
that are classics
are going to
do something and try to compete with the
technology things or change the game
because they're not just gonna they have
too much money to just die so and when
one of them does it the other five are
gonna follow very quickly so the rules
of everything are about to change so I
think will be time but like but you're
gonna get squeezed out of margin the
modern day retail realtor that's gonna
work for a Zillow or a dot this or Remax
is new direct consumer product is gonna
be a telemarketer you're gonna make 13
bucks an hour to show up and hug them
out because that's that's what you're
worth and here's what I don't know if
the economy collapses it's gonna happen
faster you go first it's real I threw
this listen this is a meta macro version
of watch what I do not what I say why
did I create agent 2021 for my health I
could have made a conference about
anything in the world
this collect and buy way it's a
hodgepodge of four different industries
you're like what's the connection point
last year but the [ __ ] like traveler I
was like yeah we're just weird maybe not
this is real carnage coming and I think
ten years from today I'm very
comfortable thinking it looks a lot
different and for a lot of people in
here that's gonna really matter go ahead
never never so it's gonna be Billie Jean
trying to sell you a product
how would it go all video people have
shown you for the last hundred years
that we read listen and watch right yeah
what was podcasting it's radio nothing
goes away humans stay the same timing is
what you need to pay attention to got it
so no people will read forever people
watch videos forever but there's timing
I think I think YouTube is an incredible
search engine yeah it's great you know
and I think YouTube pre-roll is
incredible you can run ads against
people based on what they're searching
on Google its intent it's absurd right
so then you think about that arbitrage
right now he only has to convert one and
you know 600 you know it's crazy
I've got the mic thanks Jess I love it
but you got a t-shirt you got the
sneakers I know why you're here brother
I'm firing the [ __ ] up okay ranching
yeah [ __ ] love it
yeah I get it look now that AJ and I are
in the college football game some of
these places we have to go to get Mama's
approval to sign I've seen a lot of them
there's a lot of America out there Matt
paradis our biggest our best player like
he's gonna sign the biggest contract for
a Center in football history this
offseason he played seven on seven
football in high school cuz they didn't
have enough people so I get it I got em
plus I also I got very fascinated about
Colorado and Idaho for wine-growing
towards the end of my wine kind of like
career and like did some traveling
around that too so I get it go ahead yes
yes okay
well if you talk my big thing is just
talk about your singular truth than your
uniqueness people may follow you just
for your ranching tips or because your
tire on your truck you need to change
and you videoed it I mean people think
people like I'm not interesting and I'm
like people are interesting if you
weren't interesting we wouldn't have
traffic
rubbernecking is completely based on you
know what a Yenta is not necessarily a
good you know it's more of an israeli
word necessarily than but like people
are interested in other people so you
don't have a whole lot to say about like
expertise like somebody who's been in
the business for 27 years that's her
advantage right but for now your
advantage is the documentation of trying
to make it your side hustle like if you
live streamed you're in taught somebody
in here is gonna livestream an entire
open house where nobody shows up right
and right right and then one of those at
the right time is gonna go viral as
somebody who's persevering through
adversity chewbacca mom happens a lot
you just have to put yourself in a
position somebody decided to post a
photo of an egg you understand you
understand like everybody's saying no
you are all saying no for the audience i
never say no if i would have said no for
you i wouldn't have made a cartoon photo
post and realized you guys want cartoon
photo posts for me to those comic posts
that started posting in january are
outperforming my standard content
so what do you do you just post all
sorts of [ __ ] shave your beard good
content I mean it I mean it like and you
live in a part of the world that New
Yorkers don't get this is like there's
you just never [ __ ] know but
everybody says no and I always say yes
that is literally the binary difference
and I'm willing to deal with when it's a
no because I don't care about the
judgment too many people don't do it
because they care about three likes it
doesn't look good and then that's why
everybody's doing the same [ __ ] now on
Instagram because everybody's pandering
to likes not business results how are
you two reasons I listen if Steve owned
the Lions
I'd probably own a piece of the Lions I
just [ __ ] hate the Dolphins bro I
don't even know what to say to you like
like I'm really not like economic like I
don't care about the money plus I
thought I could turn the 25 million
dollars in equity in the yeah the
Dolphins have gone up but that 25
million compounded I was confident
especially based on my track record that
I can make that 25 million go further on
the fund right now what I didn't realize
at the time was how [ __ ] special of
an investor I was when I didn't think of
myself as an investor you know I'm
really good at giving you guys business
advice on the fly because I'm coming
with clear eyes when I was not an
investor and just putting money into
things that I was clear eyes seeing they
became Facebook Twitter and Tumblr 1 2 &
3 when I got a little fancy and into the
Silicon Valley thing and starting to
think a little different or the way
you're supposed to think I made
decisions that weren't as good because
now I was high a little bit on my own
supply and what I didn't know at the
time
was going to be in hindsight my greatest
flaw as an investor I just told you all
I say yes you say no I'm so talented of
a business operator that I can deal with
my nose because my yeses are bigger than
my nose and I just keep moving forward
as an investor I took that same optimism
the problem was I wasn't running that
business I saw what they could do the
same way that I know I can run every one
of your business is better than you can
but I'm not in charge and that's where I
got caught now the good news is resi the
thing we took you know the things that I
did it's just [ __ ] it's why do you
think I basically stopped investing
anything I do gold anything I'm even
deeper in Razzie brave faith bucks
better anything when I'm clear-eyed gold
any time I'm not in control death got it
and what I just gave you was one big
macro version of experience and
self-awareness and having the humility
and the confidence to be clear with
myself there's a lot of people in here
who shouldn't be doing what they're
doing they just are aspiring to be doing
what they're doing and that's on a delta
of happiness and financial success
the ultimate is happiness and the other
access is financial success right so I'm
very cynical to real estate because then
I really am because people jump in when
it's like it's it's a money play for so
many when it's good and a hit it crashes
so hard when it's bad that's why there's
not that many people 37 27 to 15 because
like you guys are really actually in it
the amount of people that I met in 2009
missus before I knew anything about real
estate when I first got into social
media 2009 10 11 and I was popping I was
I just remember thinking like the amount
of people that literally were in real
estate before they decided to be a
social media expert by the way those
same people now are cryptocurrency
experts
guy my friend Gary your message
resonates with us thank you first of all
I come from a whole lot of [ __ ]
patriot bands in here
guide my friend 18 years yeah yeah well
because nobody knows right like every
right now you know I've been talking
about death of the economy for a little
bit longer and if people acted
immediately when I said it they probably
left some upside on the table I think we
all agree that there's a lot more talk
right now about we're concerned and it's
funny even I am such a [ __ ] by nature
countercultural dude now that everybody
else is on the bandwagon of the
economy's in trouble I'm not kidding one
of the few things I'm spending time on
is to see if I can see any indicator
that it's not so I can go like I'm
uncomfortable being with everybody right
but look I mean we here are the facts
we've been basically an economic growth
for nine years right we now have a
president whose disproportionally
leveraging the future for short term
because that's what he cares about I
understand that that's not a Trump thing
that's a that's a classic Republican
thing which will always play out right
and I have plenty of Republican
tendencies on the business side but not
the core 1 which is mortgage the future
for the current so you look good right
that's why I think George Bush desert
the who just passed away deserves
enormous credit for him to go back on
his word to write the course of the
country and but Bill Clinton gets the
credit that's the truth that's the [ __ ]
nobody talks about right so what do I
think
I think [ __ ] we're like everything is so
clearly out of whack college debt is
at a place that is so unsustainable the
remarkable amount of kids that were
propaganda to go to college because they
wanted to because it's fun or because
their parents made them that collected
debt that have absolutely no leverage in
getting a job that remotely starts
paying off one hundred sixty three
thousand dollars in debt with [ __ ]
nine percent Interest it's not
sustainable and then one thing is gonna
happen that's you know one little things
gonna happen and the whole [ __ ]
thing's gonna crash so I thought that
could happen last year I thought it
actually happened the January before if
you remember that rough little january
in the market thought it was like right
like 17 i'm trying to bright was a
junior 17 i think is right yeah yeah
like i thought that's what it was
happening cuz janet got a little rough
there couple more things so we are now
living in a generation of leadership of
40 to 80 year olds who are just not
willing to go backwards right we should
have been in the [ __ ] real recession
in 2009 we were in an eighth place
trophy recession right that's still in
the system so i I actually I think
that's Matt we're saying I don't think
it's gonna be that bad because I think
he's smart and realizes that politicians
and society won't let it be that bad
what I don't know because I just don't
is how much say do we have because it's
cool when we're the global Empire but
China is not [ __ ] around so my
intuition is that we are well into our
decline as the global Empire and we will
have to face those ramifications so I
think it's common just if I knew when
boy I would be buying up stuff right now
and sell it the hour before it happened
right so I don't know but I know it's
brewing hi
so quick question you think the Rams
have a chance in the Superbowl and I'll
go to my real husband
I think the Rams are gonna get blown out
I think the Saints got scared last week
all right so oh my god thank you for
Kayla by the way when we cut this if I'm
completely wrong cut in the final score
let's make fun of me to give away all my
content for free I wrote a book I have a
book club
thank you you Ron I love doing all this
stuff for free less that we spoke about
you created shoes and wine right to
monetize I have my version of the four
DS and but as as I'm building my brand
and it's pretty sizeable I also hold a
small mom-and-pop real estate conference
last year was my first one yeah it was
unbelievable if we ever doing it again
double the attendance for you and I have
women's trips that I host and bring 40
women all commercial real estate so I've
been I remember 32 years so besides my
workshops there are going to corporate
headquarters and teach them how to be
space do you like last night you piqued
my interest when you said you know look
I have shoes in line because well but
it's because but know this when I laid
out the game plan for well k-swiss I
only had so much say when I laid out
empathy the amount of sales from Gary be
social media that are penciled in was
zero it's a very important part it's I'm
giving you the 3.0 version of give it
away for free
expectations of your audience when you
give something away for free is the
beginning is is a real dangerous play so
I do wine and sneakers because I like
wine and sneakers and I know what to do
with them it's not that I thought that's
strategic it's to my audience right like
you know otherwise I would be actually
otherwise the only people that be able
to ask questions right now are the
people that are wearing like yourself my
sneakers I don't care that you know I I
want my thing is like look if you're
buying sneakers I'd love you to buy mine
but you know to me I didn't pick that I
definitely
wanna monetize content right back to you
know bill and by the way I don't
begrudge Billy or Schmidt or any I don't
give a [ __ ] do you Who am I
but when somebody wants to sell
something what's coming out of their
mouth is predicated on that so if I'm
gonna sell you mark anybody I promise
you everything I was doing upfront was
hedging so but what I love about you and
I've gotten to know you through four DS
and all these things Europe you're a
real [ __ ] player in my mind like if
you came to me and said I want you to
invest in business yeah but you thanks
to you yeah guess why you've been you've
been able to maintain a business for 32
years I haven't been putting out content
or 32 years maybe I was a boost or a
different angle cool and that's what I'm
here for but I think if you asked me
what would work best if you want to go
off the reservation cuz I see you a
little bit like me that way
sells something you like the best
shampoo sunglasses not strategic good
news
forty year old women that are your core
with the trips and everything else they
buy all sorts of [ __ ] got it if you
start with something you love you know I
consume sneaker content I I love wine
like I love the call it like so that's
just you know what's so great about
doing business around something you
loved you work more right like watching
my brother and Vayner sports you know
much happiness he has analyzing every my
brother analyzed every punt in the NFL
in 2017 for one of because we wanted to
position one of our clients in free
agency and [ __ ] loved it and that is
honestly that's where I think this
Nirvana is all going I think your
grandchildren look too many things will
change I think this is what you know a
lot of people like making fun of the
kids right now right they think they're
influencers they get us entitled to get
a school there think they're going to
Bali and [ __ ] look at all these
[ __ ] the reality is it's practical
have a funny feeling a lot of you [ __ ]
faces would be going to Bali too if you
could afford it
right when you were 22 if somebody's
gonna pay you to go to volley and take a
[ __ ] selfie you'd go to [ __ ] Bali
right so there's a lot of judge there's
a real glove like what the internet is
right now makes America in its greatest
land of opportunity look like a [ __ ]
hole the Internet
all right now if they're like hardcore
about getting a question in I would
definitely go outside and get in line
good well I think you know so you know
to create clarity for that I think you
guys should be on it I think you should
if you can afford if you can afford it
like I think it'd be remarkable if you
google this back to ambition you're I'm
looking at you like ambitions like if
you really want to catch the next wave
you're it's so exciting for you to be
the voice Queen right I mean this well
then [ __ ] learn how to build an Alexa
app it might take you 47 hours but you
could and then you could be on it you
could have one of the earliest Alexa by
weight you should build an Alexa app for
either $15,000 to somebody else or learn
how to do yourself just so you can say
you were one of the first people to have
one in seven years if you want to fancy
yourself as a first mover I do not fancy
myself as a first mover I fancy myself
as a remarkable observer of the current
and a better executor of the current
90,000 instead of something else for
what got it
the reason I'm on everything is I'm
[ __ ] squeezing the [ __ ] out of
everything but I wasn't when it was just
me but I decided to give up a lot of
money because I know now is the time and
I believe that attention is the ultimate
real estate because it's convertible
got it right everybody's watching you
they like you bro they like you when
you're making the videos they like you
whiskey
you could start a [ __ ] seven million
dollar whiskey brand that you sell to
Biagio for four hundred of course of
course it's the game because you like
whiskey I get it there's I'm gonna give
you a very random fun fact that very few
people on earth now the first vlogger in
our family was AJ not me because when I
was thinking up the idea I pushed him to
do Jets TV out of his dorm room a month
before I started Wine Library TV and you
know he doesn't have the same
personality traits that I do for video
but he loved it because he loves the
Jets struggling to figure out what
you're doing while you're doing your
open house talk about [ __ ] Game of
Thrones six weeks later you're gonna be
in a game of Thrones but like people
don't get it
no no no no no no no for what its
risk/reward the [ __ ] gonna happen if
you put out a video about how much you
know about exotic flowers I'll tell you
what's gonna happen
some homey that's into exotic flowers is
gonna [ __ ] buy your mortgage from you
I took a big watch what I do root beer
and wrestling and the Jets you know
crazy my wine show was like you know
what I mean like it made no [ __ ] it like
people don't think that's the way you
should do it today right you should do
the wine thing right like I was building
I was building context with my audience
from the beginning your biggest strength
is who you are it really is make a video
about the tympani lighting
you know what it just works so this
happen this happens with religions all
the time people like to buy from people
like them right
we know that go look at any subculture
any minority any ethnicity they like to
buy from each other right
they razz on each other because they
know all their moves but they deep down
like to buy from each other I'm trying
to get you to be everything that you are
and find connection points with other
somebody else is a divorcee somebody
else went to the University of Maryland
somebody else just changed her hair
color from blonde to brunette you're
leaving all the good [ __ ] because you're
listening to experts that are trying to
sell you [ __ ]
thank you
[Applause]